guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters
inshallah help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast the
following
we admire god more via his creation when
i look at my eyes i'm like
wow i don't say wow my eyes must be god
i say wow the one who's created it
so this is where we differ because the
reason why islam is so harsh against
idol worship
or any kind of worship is that it's
saying look god has created all of this
why are you can you imagine your child
who comes and says thank you ali for
looking after me i'm not thanking me is
that your mom
exactly look look that's what you just
said is profound she will get disowned
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul well the qurani
app is about to show you your progress
with your soul
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
of allah the speech of allah is
uncreated yeah okay so when allah says
out of pre-existing materials or you can
make it out of nothing because that's
his ability so when this is
his word you're confusing it with his
speech i'll tell you what i'm confusing
it
that's not what it is i just want to
make that clear i'm confusing it with
the bible that calls in the capital w
yes word yeah but don't confuse
the word in the bible and the word in
the uh two separate things
jesus that's why we have a whole chapter
on his mom and he's mentioned in the
quran because otherwise otherwise the
quran could have rejected him
you know what jesus has got nothing to
do with us but we have to affirm him
because we believe he was a true man
sent down with a true message
and that's why even in the bible jesus
claims again and again i myself can do
nothing as i see i judge and my judgment
is just
i do not see what the prophet
so when somebody says that there's a
connection when anyone says
the father there is another party
involved
so when we're talking about so if
there's any party involved
that shows that the person is limited so
this is where we differ
thank you so what we're saying is well
god in his nature can't we believe god
has
attributes the most powerful they're all
knowing the most merciful the most wise
humans no no no no so so this is very
interesting we studied this in the books
of akida that for example
god is merciful within his nature he
does not need to be
merciful in this creation so for example
no no no no no no for example are you a
mother
okay so otherwise as a mother you've
always had that mercy
even if your child was not existing i
disagree
maybe maybe maybe maybe but what i'm
saying is none of it i'm talking
about motherly love yeah that's
something unique that god has given
females
that was a mother
no no of course of course but why
because you had that in your body you
didn't have time to explore it with the
children being born
no it was my child coming that gave me
okay okay okay
okay okay so are you saying that when
your child was born you got the
attribute of mercy you never had actual
mercy i had mercy but i never had
motherly love before i was a mother
okay so what i'm saying is okay so what
we're saying is god oh my oh
god almighty always had the attribute of
mercy and love
and all know no power no but that's the
thing
god none of that but you know what
you're doing is you're using your human
attribute
to understand god i feel lonely when i'm
alone no
of course but but there's a difference
you exist god exists
but this is different yeah sure that's
what i'm saying so what we're trying to
say is
if god is alone he's not going to be i'm
so bored and lonely that's not godly
because it shows weakness
out of his mercy to uh for them to enter
paradise
he gave them an option to create them
how did he create them not to worship
him no no of course
worship what does worship mean worship
doesn't mean me praying no no no but
we're not talking about me praying five
times a day
worship is for example when i'm eating
food i say bismillah i remember him
that's a form of worship when i give in
charity it's a form of worship when i'm
good to my wife it's a form of worship
and i'm trying to say so allah created
human beings
out of not a need as in of course
self-sufficiency and yet my god at least
in his infinite wisdom yeah even though
he knows all of time and yes
he still made us knowing that hitler was
going to come along
yeah yeah he knew it
and still he loved us enough while we
were still sinners
yeah she died like to do the christian
yeah yeah yeah
so therefore i'm wondering why if he
doesn't if he's not lonely he's not
uh in need he doesn't need people yeah
why did he make
them knowing that he's going to misguide
some of them
that's very interesting you know allah
says in the quran the angels asking the
same question the angel said to him
why are you creating people that are
going to cause havoc on the earth yeah
and and he says
and this is why for example the angels
are do as they're told
yeah so here some people have a
misconception that the angels don't ask
questions
this year yeah yeah exactly that's the
reason why for example
yeah we have the jin kai yeah so we have
the angels we have the gin so what makes
us different though we have the animals
who act on instinct we have the angels
who do as they told
god almighty created man to make his own
decisions by himself
so if you act on your desires you become
like animals
if you for example do good stuff with
your own will you become better than the
angels because the angels do as they're
told
you do out of your own will so um the
question was the question i'm so sure
whenever the question is
or what is it okay so for example out of
his mercy because if he's the most
merciful
he wants to decide surely more merciful
to say
none of this is i'm gonna say no i'm
going to misguide some and not go
sometimes
no no for example the reason why dinner
is because i didn't think he's got
almighty he wants paradise
it's something that we don't deserve
oh no no no always one the purpose of
human beings is to worship
god constantly okay okay but god didn't
create god didn't create us and be like
okay you know what
i need worship if they don't worship me
i'm gonna feel if okay there we go
no no for example exactly so let me put
it like this here
you give birth to your child yeah now
your child from the get nice okay sorry
from the get-go your child when starts
getting his faculties he's gonna say my
mother looked after me
there's gonna be an instant
understanding of gratitude
yeah now you didn't give you didn't
create them to be grateful to you
you created them maybe of love or
whatever it may be yeah but
the default position of that child is to
be grateful to the mother and the father
for looking after them
do you get it yes i
does he no no no god has a will no no
will doesn't mean
god desires that people be saved that
they have that they love him
without the sin in the way yes he
desires it he doesn't need it
but he wants it he has personality
but don't you think the christians are
blessed with me blaspheming one when god
almighty
saying worship me and you're taking
jesus and saying no god
we're going to worship this is why it's
not yeah i'll just finish my sentence so
this is where we
differ because the reason why islam is
so harsh against i do worship
or any kind of worship is that is saying
look god has created all this
why are you can you imagine your child
who comes and says thank you ali for
looking after me i'm not thanking me is
that your mother no no
no exactly look look that's what you
just said is profound she will get
disowned
why no no no no i'll be honest with you
it feels like i would feel
maybe not this own but um i'm sure you
didn't mean that yeah but maybe you
know what you've said about egypt okay
okay
okay okay okay no problem that's maybe
that's that's a low blow because
everyone knows
that that's a bro cause i no no no no
i'm so sorry that was a that was a
one-hour discussion that got cut out and
it's very clear my position and i've
even explained the whole six-year-old
thing to today
my videos are this is great it's okay
i'll give you the benefit of that yeah
but what i'm trying to say is
you said you would disown your child why
because you've looked after them all
this time and this is the cross of the
matter
imagine what you're doing with god
imagine okay i'm finished imagine what
you're doing with god
he sustains you he's giving birth to you
he's giving you everything and you go
and say thanks to you
excellent right brilliant so the reason
that ali gives is that
christianity is a form of idolatry or
blessing actually
is that he can't see the obviously he
can't see the triunity of yahweh
he can't see that jesus is present in
every single book of the old testament
as well as the new testament
so in the beginning when god says let
there be light that's his word that is
jesus christ we are told in the
beginning was the word
so and the word was not only with god
but the word was god so it shows a
duality
and when we see the holy spirit
references god we see a triunity
so there's no jesus doesn't just come
along out of the blue he's prophesied in
isaiah 700 years before he comes along
he's every single book of the bible
literally the torah everything i can
show you jesus
in there so yahweh alone in the old
testament searches the hearts and minds
of men
but christ comes along we know he's not
a liar we know that
because he has the you know his mother
he has no father he's a miraculous
person
prophesied long before he comes his name
will be you know everlasting
meaning they will call him god and god
doesn't say right
stop all this don't let this baby
there's going to be too much
misunderstanding
he's the eternal son from the beginning
of time who is made flesh and therefore
we are not worshipping him as separate
to yahweh
we are worshiping him as the second
person
of yahweh of the godhead it says in the
new testament that
the father was pleased to have him
embody
the fullness of the godhead so that
means the divinity that means
he is god in the place but he does
you're right well i'm right and you
agree
he empties himself because obviously god
can't be
killed so he makes himself lesser
in order so that he can be tempted by
satan he doesn't
feel like he's not going to do it but he
makes himself
um a servant in isaiah he makes himself
lonely so that he can identify with us
and understand us in a way that really
and truly the father and the spirit
can't because they're never going to be
human
okay you know what i'm going to do um i
just want to wrap up because i need to
go as well
it was a nice discussion okay yeah it
was a nice discussion no no the reason
why i'm saying is because i found
that statement for family i'm going to
repeat that because i i i sorry
no no no it's okay no no the thing what
i found amazing is the moment i said if
your
child for example uh if you said yeah
and and and you would disown a noise
it's a natural reaction in the context
where because you
claim that i said i'll marry my daughter
no it's totally fine so the thing is is
that i've got cold clarification on my
channel um
that was a video taking out context but
you have the right as a mother that if
somebody if i heard somebody say that
out of context i myself will be worried
yeah so i understand your concern
but look at what's beautiful in this
conversation yeah no no no no no
yeah but what i'm saying is look at the
conversation here is that the moment i
said that you said you would this
owner out of care i don't care i might
disarm your life okay
okay sorry sorry okay okay you'll be
upset with that if you get this song
let's not see though
you'll be very upset with that guys and
i'm going to end this night yeah
yeah of course you want to be mercy yeah
so what we're seeing is god
guys imagine this here which is more
unjust
my child thanking someone else and i'm
upset with her
upset with her yeah imagine god creating
the heavens and the earth
and you go this is crazy this is the
pinnacle and this is why islam is so
harsh
and this is the reason why if you die on
this you end up in hell fire as long as
the message of islam didn't reach you
yeah
if you go and thank something else no
that's not jesus let's say muhammad you
go to
muhammad we believe jesus is gone no no
no i'm going to a stone or a prophet yes
or
anybody we're going to god and we're
using it yes
okay but as a muslim as muslim our point
is that he
is not god and you're making him god do
you get it why does his mother ever
write
why does the angel come and make very
impressive no problem
just the same reason why did adam critic
no further because
he had to start somewhere not exactly
but
[Music]
something that god desires so much that
he makes a miracle
to get himself because sin passes
through the father from father
child yes and therefore the curse of
adam can't come on because he's the seed
of david
but he's also the seed of the woman from
genesis with a serpent and satan
who's gonna defeat him and that's the
prophecy right from the beginning when
jesus is in
and that's and that's why women when
they give birth they carry that some
kind of burden this bible says
yeah so what i'm saying is again we
don't have that concept what i'm trying
to say is the following
jesus says look look look jesus jesus
giving life to the birth
his miraculous birth and everything he
done imagine he made the most
amazing miracles more than any prophet
it does not make him god
because you know why because let me tell
you why because the thing is
just because someone does profound
miracles you look at this let me tell
you something
when i look when i look at my watch i
bought this recently for fitness yeah
i admire steve jobs no no brother
placement i'm not getting paid for this
yet but i really admire it because it
helps me
be more active when i know i'm reaching
my goals and i admire the person who
made it
really yes well i haven't bought
so the point is this yeah when we look
at jesus and the actions he's done
we should praise god more not praise
jesus because there's
a misunderstanding happening he's not
miracles we will make him
a god and praise him was he no no no no
i believe he's god because but
but okay let me just read this because i
need to i need to go yeah what i'm
saying is the following
we admire god more by his creation when
i look at my eyes i'm like
wow i don't see wow my eyes must be god
i say wow the one who's created it when
i look at the sky
i'm like god is great when i look at you
and me like sorry for example females
sometimes
i i look at my wife and i'm amazed i'm
like look how god has
out no no no no but no but the thing is
the way god has created them from birth
to for example suckling that motherly
bond it amazes you
and the thing is what do i do i pray i
say alhamdulillah god
because the creation is so amazing that
is the difference okay
and i'm going to
it absolutely makes sense for the virgin
birth to happen because we see the seed
of the woman
is prophesied in genesis first